[MUSIC PLAYING]
ARNAB CHAKRABORTY: Good
afternoon, everybody.
Hope everybody is
doing great today.
My name is Arnab,
and this is Al.
It's a great
privilege, and we are
pretty excited that
we are here today
to talk about
artificial intelligence
and our perspective on that.
And it's really
timely, because I
don't know if you guys
saw the news today,
we at Accenture and
Google, we announced
our strategic
partnership of setting up
an Accenture-Google
business group together
and how we will drive
transformation in the industry
together around
intelligent enterprises.
So I'm personally very excited.
AL SAMBAR: I am, too.
ARNAB CHAKRABORTY: And
we will speak about that.
Just a quick background, I've
been recently relocated to US.
Prior to this, I was
in central Europe
running our applied
intelligence business out
of Germany for the
last five years.
And just been here last month
and to power up our AI agenda
in the Valley.
And Al and I have
been working together.
Al is from our
strategy practice,
leading retail and consumer
goods in North America.
And we're really trying to bring
the industry transformation
together, powered by
applied intelligence.
So very excited to be here
speaking to all of you.
So in terms of talking about
artificial intelligence,
I personally believe, being in
practice for the last 20 years,
when analytics, data,
and AI was not that cool,
I really believe
that this is really
one of the most
disruptive phenomenon we
are seeing in the world
after the great Industrial
Revolution.
We at Accenture, we believe that
artificial intelligence is not
one single bullet.
You know, it's not
one single technology.
But it's the constellation of
multiple technologies coming
together.
And these combinatorial effects
of all of these technologies
is what empowers and enables
significant business outcomes.
And that's what we're
going to talk about.
Al and I are going
to talk about today
as to how we are seeing with
our clients across industries.
How are they making
the shift to become
an intelligent enterprise?
And we are going
to talk about some
of the client examples,
their stories,
and more importantly, talk about
how to really make it happen.
You know, where to start,
how to take that journey.
You know, what are
the areas to focus on.
So we'll be focusing
a lot on that
so that you can take home from
here some of those learnings
and experiences
that both of us had.
So right off the bat,
you would see me speaking
about applied intelligence.
And that's very deliberate.
It's a strategic
choice we have made,
talking about applied
intelligence and not
artificial intelligence.
And the reason is
we believe that when
we talk about
artificial intelligence
and what it can do
for our businesses
and for our communities,
it's all about applying it,
you know?
And that's what we believe
is the true potential.
And one of the things
that we believe
is that it's also about how
humans and machines are going
to work together to create
this new form of intelligence
and apply that intelligence into
our businesses and communities.
That is going to make it fun.
That is going to
make it exciting.
So we really took a
strategic call at Accenture
to bring together
our capabilities
around data and analytics,
artificial intelligence,
and automation all together
and bring it a global business
group called applied
intelligence that
will power up new
possibilities and help
our clients re-imagine their
businesses in a completely
new way.
So as we talk about that,
let's get on the same page.
AI is a big buzz word, a lot
of definitions around it.
We wanted to share our view
on that, how we look at AI.
And our prime
belief is that it's
about creating systems
and machines, you know,
intelligent, that can
help augment human beings
to do their jobs better,
help elevate the performance
of human beings.
And when we do that,
it kind of-- you
can think of this picture,
the diagram, this [INAUDIBLE]
chart.
Think of it as a flywheel.
And, you know, it has got kind
of three concentric layers.
The black circle that
you see at the center
is really the machine
learning aspect
of AI, which really enables
machines and systems to become
much more intelligent with
every interaction, learned
through every interaction that
it goes through so that it
can improve its performance.
And today, what is
happening with AI
and what's going to
happen in the future,
I would say this is the kernel.
This is the core.
And a lot of investment
is happening here today.
A lot of advancement
is happening
in the whole machine learning,
whether it's deep learning
or shallow learning, you know?
This is going to be
an exciting space,
and it's getting
into mainstream.
What comes on top
of the learning loop
is really the end-to-end
capabilities around AI.
And as I mentioned,
it's a constellation
of multiple
capabilities, starting
from speech recognition,
text recognition, those kinds
of capabilities,
using natural language
processing, natural language
generation to things
like machine
vision, for example,
and a lot of
predictive algorithms.
You kind of mash all of that
together powered by machine
learning capabilities.
And then on top of that, it
really enables organizations
to think of what's the
out of the possible?
How am I going to apply all
of these great capabilities
to solve a business problem?
And that's extremely important.
And that's what we call
as the application layer.
These application layers could
be about an intelligent agent
for enabling better
customer interaction
and intelligent customer
interaction or personalized
customer interaction.
This could be about
creating fraud management
systems powered by machine
learning capabilities.
This could be around how do
I create a next generation
of personalized health
care for my patients
to get the best outcomes.
You know, it's like people
like us here in the room
think of different possibilities
that re-imagines the way we
run our business today.
And that's, in a
nutshell, how we
look at the whole sphere of AI.
And when we looked at applied
intelligence ourselves,
we said the vision of our
applied intelligence business
should be around the whole
sphere of human and machine
interaction and collaboration.
And today, if you look
at the newspapers,
every day there
is a lot of news,
positive news about how AI
is going to create new jobs,
new possibilities.
But there is also
another side of the news,
which says AI is going
to take away our jobs.
I think the answer lies
somewhere in the middle,
and we believe that
that's a big opportunity.
There is not so much
of a debate of how
to create that middle part and
how to apply AI in the business
to drive those outcomes and
what's the right way to start.
And we believe that there
was a need for a management
guide for business
executives like all of us
here to chart that out.
And we came up with this book
called "Human Plus Machine,"
which is really a
management guide to how
to drive the AI agenda.
Our CTO, Paul Doherty, and our
managing director, Jim Wilson,
both of them penned this book.
And it became a best seller
over the last few months.
I would strongly recommend
you to kind of take
a look at this book.
I mean, when I read this book,
what comes to me every time,
having been in practice
for the last 20 years,
is that AI is not
futuristic, you know?
It's been there for
the last 40, 50 years.
And what's making it real
now is the availability
of computing power, the
availability of data,
and all the APIs that
are available today.
That's making it real.
Today, we are
looking at companies
who are using deep learning
and machine learning
capabilities to sequence the
entire human genome, you know,
for coming up with personalized
medicine and personalized
treatment.
At the same time, we are
looking at speech recognition
capabilities and
algorithms that is really
enabling the next generation
of human interaction, customer
interaction, and almost
being representing
the brand of the company.
You know, where AI is
becoming the new UI
for the whole company.
And this is happening
right here, right now.
And that's what we believe,
that AI is happening.
It's available, it's
achievable, and it's affordable.
And that's makes the whole
discussion so much more
exciting.
So some of the seminal research
that we did over the last six
to eight months, we interviewed
about 1,000-plus business
executives across the globe.
A few key things came out, and
I want to share with this group.
First and foremost, 85% of the
executives that we interviewed
indicated that they are going to
invest in AI in the next three
years.
So obviously, a lot
of optimism around it.
We did the research
around understanding.
You know, how major economies
and global industries
are kind of looking
at adopting AI.
And our research
showed that applying AI
is going to help improve
profitability on an average
to about 38% when you look
at all the major industries.
It also showed us
that it's going
to have a huge potential
boost to the economy
output in the order of
about 14 trillion US dollars
when we look at the 12 major
economies across the globe.
What it also showed us was that
the whole labor productivity is
going to increase
by 40%, you know,
when you look at the time
horizon between now and 2035.
And the premise was
really around AI
being able to help augment
the human workforce,
keeping people at the center.
But also a big focus around
the whole interaction
between human and machine,
where the machine is
doing a part of the
work, handing it over
to a human being,
and vise versa.
A new level of
collaboration will
start, which is going
to completely re-imagine
the future of work and
future of our workforce.
And that's going to be
extremely, extremely exciting
and interesting, you know, as
we are going to witness that.
So having talked about
all of that optimism
and all of that potential
that AI and the capabilities
are bringing together,
what does that
pivot means to being an
intelligent enterprise, right?
And Al and I am
going to now spend
the time to talk
about the examples
of our different
client industries.
But I want to kind of hone on
some of the core principles
or traits that we are seeing
with a lot of the successes
that organizations are
having in their AI journey.
And these are around
the four broad teams.
The first one that I
would like to highlight
is about how AI is
enabling companies
to become much more
flexible, much more agile.
And I call it as, you know,
re-imagining the whole business
process, which is not static,
which is not rule-based,
which is not just following the
standardization principles that
has happened in the 90s
and the early 2000s.
But really re-imagine
the entire business
process that I call as
living as adaptable, which
is going through a virtual cycle
and a constant learning loop,
just taking all the
signals coming in
from the different data
sources, and then taking
the actions and decisions
and constantly learning.
And that creates a
completely new dynamism
around how we manage our
businesses and processes
globally.
The underlying factor around
creating a living and adaptable
process is really the data
and availability of data
and making real-time decisions.
And that means the second big
trait for AI-led companies
is to become data
natives, empowering
all of our associates
and workforce to be savvy
with data, to be having access
to all the data that is needed
to do their jobs
better, and ability
to make real-time decisions with
the power of data and insights.
It has a huge mindset
shift that happens
when you move from a
process-centric organization
to a data-driven business model.
It's a different
mind shift and needs
a lot of cultural change, a
lot of leadership commitment,
really, to walk the talk.
And then the third big area
is around the network effect.
And the way I characterize
network effect
is how you take a success
in one part of the business
and really democratize
that and industrialize that
across the entire organization.
Successful companies
are able to do that.
And when you do that,
you are following
the whole constant learning loop
cycle, which doesn't recognize
organizational boundaries.
You are breaking the silos that
exist within the organization.
Not just within
your organization,
but across your extended supply
chain, what with your customers
as well as with your suppliers.
And that creates a completely
new set of exponential growth
opportunities.
And when we do
all of these, it's
very important to really
be responsible in terms
of how we deploy the AI
systems into our business
or into our daily
lives, into our society,
and so on, and so forth.
And I'm going to
talk about that as we
go through the
presentation this is
going to be a very
important aspect
to create trust and reduce the
skepticism and concerns that
are there with AI.
So I wanted to leave you
all with these four teams.
And now we are going to delve
into the examples, where
we will touch upon this
and bring it to life.
And with that, I want to
welcome Al and walk us
through some of the examples.
AL SAMBAR: Thank you.
Thank you, Arnab.
A pleasure to be here.
I'm excited to talk about it.
We're going to talk about
four different industry
examples of how we think about
applying applied intelligence.
And some in the audience
probably care about how,
and how we used it.
And we'll definitely talk about
that and be open to some Q&A
on the mechanics of what we do.
But I would also imagine for
most of my conversations--
I do strategy work, so
most of my questions
are usually starting with a why.
What's the business case
for applied intelligence?
What's the return on investment?
It's a significant investment
if your organization
comes from a history of
having never done it before.
So the examples
we're going to show,
and essentially all
of our examples,
really hit on these
five use cases.
So if you're out there,
charged for your team
with creating a business
case around investing in AI,
look to these five.
I think you'll find it.
But as a broad
coaching, I would tell
you applied
intelligence is going
to change how our consumers
experience our product
and services.
They are going to
change what even
we sell as products
and services, how
those products and services--
what products and
services we should sell
will be influenced by AI.
And then lastly,
which you're going
to see a lot in the
examples, how we operate
as a business because of AI.
The first industry we'll pick
on is consumer engagement.
So think about
brands and retailers
and how the consumers
experience us.
Let's set up a little
bit of the problem state.
Where is the industry today,
and where is it going?
How is technology changing it?
Just like we talked about
how dramatic this digital
revolution is, if you're
selling products, either as
a retailer or a brand that's
selling to the customer,
in this industry,
this is what you face.
You face an explosion
of channels,
not just that are new ways of
connecting to your customer
and sharing information
with your customer,
but every one of
these channels--
I don't care who
your partner is.
Every one of these channels
now has development kits
and technology
available to be able,
in the moment of that
content being delivered,
take the order.
We, as product
companies and retailers,
haven't yet built
the infrastructure
to satisfy that order.
But what the customer
sees is that the moment
that they feel a
moment of desire,
they can reach out to somebody
they trust and say I want it.
So we, as retailers,
have to adapt to this.
We have to understand and
invest in how to build that.
But if you think about a
traditional retail or a brand
being able to handle
all of the choices
that I have to make about what
content to put in which channel
and how to talk to each
individual consumer,
that's overwhelming
and not doable
with our current
historic infrastructure.
So we, as retailers
or brands, grew up
and built companies
and business models
built around wholesale business
models, where I bring product
from manufacturer
to then consumer.
But all of a sudden, if
across all of those channels
I'm going to have all this
persistence of relationships,
and I'm going to remember
who my customer is
in all of those moments so
I can respond appropriately,
it changes the fundamental
platform of retailing.
We still need all the old
platform essential elements,
the means of
production, the means
of getting that supply to
market, stores who distribute,
marketing to bring
the customer demand.
But the essence of
our relationship
changes, because of all
of these digital channels.
So we start where--
I grew up in an industry where I
could go and talk to a customer
to drive growth.
I could increase their traffic.
I could increase their
conversion rate or their basket
size.
Those were all the
levels of the business.
But today, if we're going to
drive growth in our businesses,
we really have to move revenue
spending of that customer,
and we have to do
it competitively.
So some of you will recognize
the LTV yield equation
on the lower left side, but if
you're a traditional retailer,
you never built your
motor to do that.
So how do I start thinking
about all the revenue dollars,
the share of wealth that
I have with that customer,
the share of occasions,
the share of use,
and really optimize when and
how I'm servicing and touching
that customer?
Can't do that with just my
historic processes and systems.
You really need two things.
You need the ability to
predict an individual customer,
what their desires are and
how those desires change
over the use occasion
and where they might
be at that moment in time.
And most of our customers or
clients might have a Laura.
But we're not talking about
a Laura as a personality.
We're talking about
Laura J. Smith that
lives on 123 Maple Drive
and goes to work here
and transits on this hub.
That is a profound
difference for the way
we've built our
companies and how
we make decisions about how to
deploy money to drive demand.
So it's profound in retail.
And then secondly, is
when I get that demand,
and she says I have desire and
she's able to reach out to me,
because I've built
these digital channels,
how do I get that
service to her?
How do I engage all
my trading partners?
How do I make the right
decision about what
inventory to bring her and
who should bring it to her?
I can't do that
with just people.
I need two super
power these people.
So I'll give you a
little example of where
we did it with one retailer.
This retailer provides
services, products and services.
And when we walked
into the client,
they had gone on a
little bit of hiring.
They were going to learn
to use data and analytics,
and they had hired
some data scientists.
And those data scientists were
doing multivariate testing.
In this particular example, I'm
talking about how to market.
So they started with
marketing in this example.
And those data scientists,
each individual one
could do about three
multivariate tests.
And a good, well-run
executable multivariate test
would give them results
in three to six weeks
depending on the
complexity of the test.
And you can understand
that if you understand
all those marketing
channels that we just
put up on that board earlier.
Think about all the
permutations if I'm
going to go place
an ad on search,
or I'm going to place
something on YouTube,
something on Instagram,
or I'm going to place
something on Facebook.
And then think about
making decisions
across all of those things.
The permutations of what content
and what decisions and what
offer are huge.
And we were using
data scientists
to really mathematically tackle
that and scale-- tackle that
at about one of those good
tests, a couple of those tests,
every three to six weeks.
So the reality is
we said we need
to get this so you don't need
to be a data scientist to do it.
How might I use
applied intelligence
to look at all
those permutations
to let a person who's charged
with growing demand and growing
revenue yield in this market
pick the targets that she think
is important for her strategy?
Like, how do I retain
my existing customers?
How do I optimize the lifetime
value of a high-value customer?
How do I target cross-selling
different products?
How do I increase market basket?
Let business users ask
business questions,
and let machines scale the
quality of that question
by running tens of thousands
of multivariate tests,
then iterate across
all those permutations.
Once you understand that--
and I'll use marketing,
because it's relatively--
understand all the permutations
we have to make as
decision makers.
But once you understand that
and build an organization that
can start to use machine
learning and data in that way,
you don't just
stop at marketing.
You start thinking
about, well, I
might think about my product
completely different.
I might test and add
unique product by market.
I might modify my market.
I could test that product
before it ever comes.
I'm certainly going to use
this for price promotion
and placement.
It's probably one of the most--
as we get to last mile delivery
everywhere, placement
becomes a strategic place
to use AI that drives the
profitability of your firm.
So I used a simple example,
but hopefully the idea
comes across.
In consumer products
and retail, it's
the plethora of emerging
ways the consumer can
talk to us and the need for us
to talk to them individually
that requires us to
use machine learning
and applied intelligence.
And none of these
examples did we take away
the role of the person.
We completely
redefined their job.
I'm going to turn it back to
you to cover the next section.
ARNAB CHAKRABORTY: Thank you.
Thank you, Al.
That's so powerful, you know?
As you talk about how we
can re-imagine the whole way
to engage with
customers and consumers,
and we being all in this space.
You know, this is amazing.
I mean, the way--
right now, for example,
Netflix or Amazon, the way
they are engaging
with all of us.
I mean, all the
investments they have
done over the last
many years is really
acting the flywheel effect
we can start seeing, right?
So yeah, thanks for
sharing that story.
So I'm going to take
a little switch now
from the consumer to the food
and agriculture industry.
And this is something
close to me,
given I am such a big foodie.
We are seeing a huge
application of AI
in the field of agriculture.
When you look at
agriculture today,
statistics shows that
across the world,
there are over 795 million
people who don't get access
to quality food.
As we look at the
growth of the population
globally, over
the next 50 years,
the amount of food
that has to be produced
in different
agricultural farms is
going to be much higher
than what has happened
over the last 10,000 years.
And how can AI really
enable to re-imagine
agricultural
operations and empower
farmers to make decisions,
every-day decisions,
with the power of intelligence
that is coming in?
It's a complete change and
shift in their business model.
We have been working
with this client, who's
a big agricultural manufacturer.
Have acres, millions of
hectares of agricultural land.
And the challenge
they are faced with
is a lot of the decisions
in terms of which part
of the know farm with thousands
and thousands of trees
and plants being grown--
where to put their attention.
Typically, they do a
sample size and people
would go into the fields, and
they will do their samples.
And they'll come back, and
then they do an analysis.
Based on that, they will take
a lot of gut feel decisions.
How is the weather going
to look like tomorrow?
You know, what kind
of soil condition
we are seeing today
in the sample set?
Where should I actually do
more nutrient injection?
Where do I need to
water my plants better?
And so on, and so forth.
It's a hugely manual
process, you know?
And this is where we came in.
And we worked with this client
over the last couple of years,
initially a pilot.
Now we are providing a
precision agriculture service,
which is nothing but
AI at the center of it,
starting with being
a data native.
Being a data native,
helping the client
to actually look at
data that is coming
in from aerial images
with drones flying
on the top of the agricultural
farmlands, taking aerial images
of--
to show the kind of distress
that the crops might be at,
which is not possible
when you go down there.
Looking at IoT devices emitting
soil chemical composition
information as well
as weather information
and triangulating all of that
into a cloud-based platform,
applying machine learning,
and a lot of machine vision
capabilities on top of
that, to really come up
with predictive recommendations
that can go up to the farmer
and on their mobile
device, really
giving them guidance
and assistance
in terms of what specific
intervention needs
to be made that particular
day, that particular week,
based on all the multiple
parameters that we are seeing
coming in from the soil
information, the weather
information, the
color of the leaves,
whether there is wheat
formation happening somewhere,
which parts of the plantation
that's not actually
growing properly,
and giving very
personalized recommendation
and targeted recommendation
for the farmer.
Taking it one step
further, you know,
integrating that intelligence
back into the work management
system of the broader
agricultural company
to help deployment of the right
resources in the right way,
in a smarter way.
And as we do that, think about
the living adaptive process
that I mentioned earlier.
You know, the farmer, the
agricultural operations
manager, they became part
of that learning loop.
And they received
the recommendation.
They looked at the
recommendation, took an action.
The feedback was good.
They looped back the feedback
into the learning system.
If the result was
not that great,
they also provide that feedback.
As a result of that, the whole
precision agricultural engine
started becoming smarter
over period of time.
And then it scale from applying
to one particular farmland
to hundreds of those farmlands
across different crop varieties
over a period of six months.
And that's AI at scale.
You know, industrialize
across their businesses
and really completely
changing a mind shift.
This company came from a
mind shift of in the past,
you know, they would
take more rule-based,
experienced-based decisions.
And today, it's all
happening with data,
becoming a data native
and really living
the new adaptive
agricultural process,
where the farmers and the
agricultural machine operators,
all of them are part of
the new AI learning system,
providing feedback on every
interaction, every iteration.
And what does it result in?
It results in higher
yield of the produce,
better quality, optimization
of resources, water resources,
nutrients, human labor.
And primarily, it's
augmenting the human
to actually-- whether it's
the farmer or the operator,
agricultural operator,
to make better decisions,
make better profits,
serve people like you
and me with better
quality of food.
So that's one story I wanted
to share in terms of a journey.
This is going on.
It's a big
transformation journey.
And based on the success--
and I had an
opportunity of meeting
the person who is running it.
He's a 28-year-old guy.
This is a family-run business.
He's the son of the
CEO and chairman.
And he's running it.
And he's creating a
completely new cultural shift
within their
enterprise, which was
kind of an archaic business.
And now this is the cool
part of the business, which
is completely changing
the way they operate
and the way they move forward
in the business moving forward.
So the next one that I wanted
to talk about from there,
since that--
I know I've talked about food,
and all of you are hungry,
I guess, or had your lunch.
The next one I
want to talk about
is really about creating
safe and secure society.
And this is really
happening now, you know?
What you're seeing here is
from the city of Singapore.
And they have an initiative
called Safe City.
And we had an opportunity
of partnering with them
to really look at all
non-structured data that
is coming in from video
recordings, that is coming
in from all the natural
text information, web chat
information, social
media information.
Looking at all the traffic
signals and traffic patterns,
and how to create a command
center, an AI-driven command
center that will help the
government to monitor cloud
movements across the cities.
Understanding and
predicting how the cloud
behavior is going to look
like on a particular day
of the week.
On a particular big
event day or a game day,
how does it look like?
And based on that
understanding, how
can we optimize the whole
setting of the city right
from traffic
management to taking
care of any kind of emergency?
You know, prevention,
how many resources
we need to apportion
for taking care
of any kind of risks that might
happen, so on, and so forth.
You know, that's kind
of a new capability
that has been developed.
What it also does is--
not just looking at predicting
cloud behavior, but also
anticipate what
kind of incidents
can happen that
might have a security
threat or any kind of risk.
And how do you actually
predict those in advance
and then prepare for those
kind of events in advance,
so that you are not
taken by surprise?
When you look at this example,
it's not about-- just about
how we are industrializing
and scaling this capability,
but it's also about
a new capability
that is just not possible
with human beings,
and how we are
helping human beings.
And one of the example is--
for example, there's
a game day going on,
and thousands of people like
us, we go into the game you
into the stadium.
One person went with a backpack,
and then after two hours
comes out without the backpack.
The human being is just
not going to make that out.
But the machine realizes
that and gives an alert.
This is a simple example, right?
And obviously, it has to be done
in a way that it's responsible,
it takes care of
privacy, and so forth.
But this is a completely
new capability
that, if you can scale,
is going to create
a more safe and
secure environment
for the entire city.
And you can scale it
across multiple cities.
I mean, in the country that
I'm coming from in India,
our new government,
new minister,
there's a big initiative
around digital cities.
You know, there
are 100 cities that
are getting digitalized and
using this Smart City concept.
And the advantage of AI
is that you can actually
scale this pretty fast.
Once you have
proven the success,
you can then
replicate that model
pretty quickly across
the other cities.
And that, I think,
is a huge, huge power
that impacts all of us.
The third example that
I wanted to share,
this is something we are
playing to ourselves.
I think Al alluded to that.
We at Accenture, we run--
apart from the work
that we do in terms
of developing the
strategy for our clients,
executing that strategy
through technology deployment,
re-imagining the whole
digital transformation.
And then finally, we help our
clients manage the operations,
you know?
And this is a big
business for Accenture.
And as we speak, over the
last two to three years,
we are transforming ourselves.
We are re-imagining how
we manage the business
processes of our client.
And we are applying
AI at the core of it.
Two, three key dimensions.
One of that is obviously
to take cost out.
But the bigger purpose
is, how do we actually
enable our associates?
You know, we have 100,000
associates working
in that part of the business.
How we enable those
associates to do
much higher value added work?
How we enable managing
those processes
in a completely new way
that is powered by AI
so that it's more accurate?
You know, it's compliance-ready.
It's helping us to manage
any kind of fraud that
might be happening.
It enables us to manage
better customer relationships
and supply relationships.
And that's really
the core purpose,
you know, as to why we are
re-imagining our own business
process, business operations
with the power of AI.
The example here I took from
was on invoice management.
In a year, we work with about
2,000 clients in the space--
200 clients in this space
with over 70 million invoices
that goes through Accenture.
You know, we are responsible for
authenticating those, managing
those, validating those.
It was done with over 6,000-plus
full-time-equivalent employees
who are doing that.
It was a hugely manual process.
And we brought in artificial
intelligence and machine
learning at the core
of it that completely
re-imagined this process.
What we are doing here-- and
we're working very closely with
Google in driving this, where
we are using basically Google
Vision API, which is
really a powerful,
out-of-the-box capability
that is helping us to extract
the natural text that is there
in the invoice picture along
with the spatial information
of that particular picture.
And then bringing that
together, concatenating
that together to
extract features
from those concatenations.
And we created what
we call as basically
these digitalized
tokens, you know?
A word with a position,
where it is placed.
And each of them we are
uniquely identifying
as digitalize tokens.
And then we are making
multiple vectors
around those tokens to
help create features
that uniquely define that.
And then those
features are then used
to train the deep learning
models, which are then fed back
into the live system
of all the invoices
that we have to validate that,
to check for issues, errors,
if there is any kind of
potential fraud or compliance
issue, and flag
that to the humans.
And then the human
associate doesn't
have to do all the grunt work
that was being done earlier,
but now is more in
an advisory role
and is more in a
supervisory role,
whereas all the grunt work
of validating, checking,
and accuracy, and all of
that is being checked.
And then there is a
green light given.
And if there is a
green light given,
and the human agent has approved
it, it goes on for processing.
If there are fraud or
compliance-related issues
or missing information or
some duplicate information,
some conflicting information,
that's flagged off as well
to the human agent.
And then the human
agent accordingly
takes more supervisory and
advisory kind of function
from there.
And the fact that
we are deploying it
on Google technology
with the Cloud Platform,
it has really helped us scale
from one client to 200 clients
today.
And the fact that we are
managing 70 million invoices
in a year, it gives us a
huge amount of data sets
with different form
factors of invoices,
different kind of text
orientations, and all of that
to train and make our
intelligent engine much more
efficient as days go by.
And we are right now
over 90%, 95% accurate
in terms of checking the
validations of these invoices.
So that's a huge impact for us.
It helps us give better
service to our clients.
At the same time, creates
a much more foolproof
for business process system.
So having talked about
the other examples
that Al talked
about on consumer,
you know, we talked about from
how it helps with agriculture,
whether it's about re-imagining
our own business process,
I want to kind of spend
time a little bit now
in terms of how to get it right.
I mean, all of these
are great stories.
We talked about some
of the examples.
And I want to touch upon three
key tenets or secret sauce
that we are seeing that
is very important to get
the intelligent
enterprise journey right.
The first and
foremost that we are
seeing with clients who
are very successful in this
is really figuring out the
human-machine collaboration.
You know, this is the first
C. The collaboration C.
This is extremely important,
because human beings
have certain strengths around
creativity, decision making,
judgment, whereas the
machines have strength really
around doing things in
a repeatable manner.
High accuracy,
high speed, right?
How do we bring that
together and design
systems, AI systems that really
take care of these two angles
very well?
This is going to be
very, very important.
It is going to address
the fact whether humans
are going to compete.
Absolutely no.
Humans are going to work
together with machines
powered by these AI systems.
And you can think
of it almost as
if human ingenuity is
actually getting complemented
with intelligent technology.
And organizations need to really
figure this out very well.
And this is not just
a technology play.
It is about re-imagining
the whole persona
as to who is going
to use that system,
you know, whether it's that
agricultural farmer, whether it
is the customer, value manager,
or a marketing manager,
whether it's the supply
chain manager, whether it
is the event manager.
Who is going to
use the AI system
and how he or she can
then work with the machine
to actually create a
much higher performance,
much higher outcome?
And keeping that design thinking
in mind when you develop the AI
system is extremely critical.
So that's the first C.
The second big focus is
really around capabilities
and capabilities
that are end-to-end.
And I wanted to touch upon
this, because people sometimes
feel that capabilities means
technology, which we have all
talked about so far, all
the different algorithms,
the machine learning
capabilities.
Yes, that is great, but
that's just one part
of the capability.
The second big part of the
capability that is required
is the fuel for the
whole AI system.
That's the data.
That's the data platform.
How do you get your data
supply chain in place?
Because that's going to be the
concrete asset on top of which
you will be actually building
all of these AI systems.
It's also about how do
you then embed the AI
system into your
business functions,
into your business processes?
And that requires a different
skill, different capability
on adoption, around
change management,
around making sure that
employees are really
believing in it.
And there is a tangible
value for the employees
in the organization.
And how do you bring all of
these end-to-end capabilities
right from having a strategy
of AI to actually creating
the platform, enabling all of
these different capabilities
that we spoke about earlier?
And then how do you manage
the change and the adoption
into the business?
That creates real
transformation.
And then the third
one that I want
to speak about is as you
think of these capabilities,
how do you go about
building those?
And that's where the third
C, which is the connections,
is extremely important.
And we are seeing that.
And we did a big research
on this last year
around how to increase the
artificial intelligence
quotient of organizations.
And we saw that
the companies which
are taking an outside-in
approach-- by that,
I mean taking an approach
of bringing innovation,
not just from within, but from
outside, working with startups,
working with
research institutes,
working with academia.
They get a boost start
compared to the companies
which are trying to do
everything in-house.
So a critical decision factor
that every leading organization
in the AI space will
have to think about
is what they build
on their own, what
is it that they want to buy
from a service provider,
and what is it that
they borrow, what is it
that they get inspired
with, you know,
using the power of startups or
the academia or the research
partners.
And I think that
partnership ecosystem
is going to be extremely
critical, especially
as we scale the AI agenda
within the companies.
So having spoken
about that, I want
to leave with this
last thought is
that as we think of
re-imagining the business,
as we think about creating
the transformation,
we have to do it in a
very responsible way.
AI is a profound technology.
It has a huge value potential.
But how do we make
sure that there
is a certain level of
accountability that
comes in when we are
deploying AI systems?
How do we make sure that
organizations are thinking
about every stakeholder?
Not just the customer,
not just the supplier.
The employees, the
government, the policy makers,
how we think of all of
those stakeholders, right?
And how do we create a right
amount of governance model
and operating model to see--
as decisions are being
taken by AI systems,
who takes the accountability?
Whether it is the algorithm
which is accountable,
whether it is the person
who made the algorithm is
accountable, whether the
person who is actually
the sponsor of this
whole initiative--
who are accountable for that?
And these are questions that
needs to be really thought
through very, very carefully.
And as you go through
that transformation,
think about the people.
Think about the people that
need to be the rescaled, that
needs to be rotated
into the new AI journey
so that we don't leave anybody
as we go into the journey.
How do we take the people
who probably are not skilled,
who really don't
understand and appreciate,
how do we educate them?
How do we make them the
advocates of the AI journey?
And more importantly,
how do we make
them successful in their career
and in their journey with AI?
And last, but not
the least, security.
How do we make it
all very secure,
so that there is no bug
that comes into the AI
algorithm, which is running
a manufacturing operations
or a customer operations?
Because there is a
lot of liquidation
risk associated with that.
How do we manage that in
a very responsible manner?
So with that, I would like
to bring it to a close here.
Personally, being in the
practice for so many years,
I feel this is an amazing field.
A few things I want
us to remember--
that AI is all about
augmenting human beings.
How do we think about creating,
living adaptable business
processes?
And how do really make sure that
we are all becoming data native
and enabling that new culture
within the organization?
And as we do that,
how do we make sure
we do it in a way
that's responsible?
It creates trust, transparency,
and addresses people's concerns
and take them together
in that journey.
[MUSIC PLAYING]